meanwhile as he mentioned uh the effects
of the businesses here in las vegas
business owners here in southern nevada
they say keeping a restaurant open
during a pandemic it's hard enough just
to keep the lights on essentially
imagine trying to open one start it from
complete scratch
as the restrictions are constantly
changing we have hector mejia live this
morning in the arts district and hector
you spoke with one business owner who's
taken a chance
and opening during these very tough
times
yeah good morning john and you know it's
already a very challenging time for the
industry we are at mainstream provisions
where they're getting ready to open
two days from today the owner tells me
restaurants in general
already operate on very thin margins but
they're still moving forward during the
pandemic
and opening anyway they actually hired
local artists to create some of the
displays you see in here the rings you
see on the wall
those are pieces of pipes and all the
way on the other side of the room
the other wall that entire side of the
wall is a mural created by another
artist
and i'm told location adds a bit of a
boost right now
main street provisions is adding its own
twist to comfort food here in the arts
district
they'll start with 12 employees and
three managers but the hope is to hire
up to 28 people
after restrictions on restaurants ease
up they've been training
cooking getting ready to open at 25
percent capacity that means they can
only see
37 guests at a time they told us plants
came
to a grinding halt as they tried to open
in the first month of the pandemic
owner kim owens says they're also
creating a menu specifically for
curbside pickup
as they try to keep up with the times
positive and hopeful is all i can do i
don't believe in in letting things drag
you down
you just pull yourself up by your
bootstraps you figure out how you're
gonna make it work
um you take care of your employees you
make sure the places
that you make sure that the location the
restaurant the retail store wherever you
are
is safe for your guests and you just
forge forward
owen says staff go over safety every day
we're talking about
hand washing making sure staff don't
touch their face
making sure everyone is wearing a face
mask and maintaining that social
distance
and the nevada restaurant association
says that back in
april at the start of the pandemic 15
of restaurants in nevada were forced to
close because of the coveted
restrictions
and as we get ready to close out the
this year we'll have the latest
projections from them still ahead
in the next half hour reporting live
hector mejia 8 news now